-Welcome to the show.
Thank you so much for coming on.
That's how you make an entrance
right there -- to dance on.
I love it.
I want to talk about
a bunch of things.
But "If Beale Street
Could Talk" --
is it true that was
your first movie ever?
-Yes, yes.
-Really?
Walk me through that,
'cause it kind of changed
everything for you, right?
-It did. I mean, whew, wow.
Booking "Beale Street," I mean,
that was a dream come true
and, like,
the most on-time blessing
because I was broke
when I book --
[ Laughter ]
...booked "If Beale Street
Could Talk."
-Oh, really? How broke?
-Literally, they flew me out
to New York.
And so, you know, when you go
to check into a hotel,
they take your card,
they put a hold on the card?
So I gave them my card
and they said,
"Okay, we're going to put
a $100 hold."
I said, "Ooh."
[ Laughter ]
I said, "Okay,
let's pray on that.
Let's -- Whew."
-[ Laughs ]
Wait, you're like,
"Do I have a hu--
I don't know if $100
is going to work."
-So, thankfully, thankfully,
we had it.
-Wow.
-But I went up to my room
and I checked my account,
and I had $114 total
in my account.
So, now I only had
$14 available.
-Look at this.
It's just unbelievable,
the whole story.
-Yeah.
I don't even think
I've said this before.
Like, I literally --
I showed up.
So, that morning,
I spent the $14 on breakfast.
So, when I showed up
to my chemistry read
with Barry and Stephan,
who had already been cast,
I had no money in my account.
-Zero.
-No money.
-Wow.
-Seriously. So I showed up --
I think it actually
affected the energy
that I brought into the room of
like, "I have to book this."
[ Laughter ]
Like, "if I don't book this,
I don't know
what's going to happen."
And it's funny because at some
point, Barry offered me water.
He said, "Hey, Kiki, you want
some water or anything?"
I said, "No, no thank you,
I'm okay."
And he made this joke.
He said, "Oh, okay, she's not
thirsty -- she's hungry.
She don't need water.
She's hungry."
-Wow.
-And I was thinking,
"Oh, Barry."
You have no idea."
-"You have no idea."
[ Laughter ]
-"I am hungry." Yeah.
And you got it, and you
knocked it out of the park.
-Thank you.
-I mean, nominated for Oscars.
You went to --
You presented at the Oscars.
-I did. Hoo!
-I mean, to go from that to that
must be mind-blowing.
-Oh, yeah.
The entire "Beale Street"
press run experience --
I mean, one,
it was just a huge --
just so many dreams coming true
night after night.
But Oscar night
was even more special
because I brought my mom.
-Yeah.
-See, that's exactly why
you're awesome.
Did you go, uh,
after-parties with Mom, too?
-I did. We -- Oh, we had a --
Me and my mama --
My mama loves
a good party, okay?
She is a fun time.
-Yeah.
-I kind of -- It's funny.
I was kind of living more
vicariously through her,
because I was trying
to play it cool.
I'm just like, "Oh, it's fine.
It's my first Oscars.
It's totally fine.
I'm cool, I'm cool."
And my mom, "Oh, my goodness!
Hi! Hello!
Oh, my God, let me get a selfie.
Yes, take a picture with me.
That's my baby.
That's my baby,
Kiki Layne, yes."
[ Laughter ]
-She's getting
selfies and stuff?
-Yes. Yes.
-Like, what -- what --
who was at the parties?
What kind of parties
did you end up going to?
-The Oscar parties were crazy,
'cause you'll be just
on the dance floor
having a good time,
drinking, whatever it may be.
And then you'll turn around.
And it's like, "Cool, that's
Beyoncé and Jay-Z. All right."
-No.
-"So, I'm going to keep
twirling over here."
[ Laughter ]
-I don't even know if I've ever
even seen Jay-Z dance.
-Oh, he -- he's got some moves.
-He does?
-Oh,yes. Yes, he does.
-And what is your go-to jam?
Just any song?
-Um, let's see.
Right now, I'm asking for --
to hear "Have Mercy"
by Chloe a lot.
That's like --
Love that song, right?
-Whoo!
-Yes. That's right, look,
that's right.
Um, and then, like, a classic,
like, forever,
no matter how many years
have passed,
like, classic "I have to
dance to this song" song --
"Back That Azz Up."
[ Laughter ]
By Juvenile.
That's right.
-Are you one of those people
that go to the DJ
and request songs?
-Absolutely.
-Really?
I don't care if they have a sign
that says, "No requests."
I will request a song.
-Quest?
He says no.
-Yes.
-I was the DJ that night, too.
-Oh, really?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's so funny.
That's so funny.
Quest as the DJ, jamming out.
Right, he's a great DJ, but --
-But see, I make great requests.
Because, see, I think --
-I don't.
-Oh. Ohh.
-I have a little something
and then I'll be like,
"Questlove.
Yo, Quest, play
'We Are the World.'"
[ Laughter ]
I want to talk about
a couple of things.
'Cause our buddies
made this movie
"Chip and Dale: Rescue Rangers."
I love Akiva Schaffer.
It's a mix of animated and real.
-Yes.
-And also, like, a little salute
to animation, as well.
-Yeah.
-And are you "in it"
in it, or voice in it?
-So, I am "in it" in it.
I'm a live action lead,
but it was funny because
our first trailer just came out.
And at the end is this beautiful
list of, like, all these iconic,
like, great comedians,
great actors.
And then there's my name.
And I'm like, "Cool.
I didn't actually work
with any of these people."
-"I never met any of this cast."
-Right.
Like, I -- I wish.
I mean, it's such
an incredible cast.
But I didn't get to work
with any of them.
It was just me, by myself,
like, running around
pretending to talk
to Chip and Dale.
-To chipmunks. Okay, good.
That's acting, right?
-Right.
-Andy Samberg, John Mulaney,
uh, yeah. They're the best.
I want to talk about --
you made your stage debut.
I love that you decided to go
back to stage and theater.
Is that where you got
your start?
That's what made you do it,
or you just go like,
"I love the script"?
-I had been yearning to --
to be on stage again
for like a few years actually.
And then when this script
came around, I mean,
Aleshea Harris,
the playwright, is such an --
it's such beautiful language
and storytelling.
And, like, I had been yearning
to dig a bit deeper
into my craft,
and this script
allowed me to do that.
And it's been such
an incredible experience.
Just being on stage
and collaborating,
and this very special way
that we collaborate
and tell stories on stage
has been a gift.
-And there's nothing
like a live audience.
-Yeah. Hey.
-Yeah, exactly right.
Kiki Layne, everybody.
"On Sugarland" is running
through Sunday
at the New York Theatre
Workshop.